all right Leandra yes Leandra oh where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally I grew up in Chino California
I was born in
um Oregon but my parents moved on when I
was about three so Chino tell me about
your parents your family
um I'm the oldest of four siblings so
we're all two years apart
and then um
I was also homeschooled growing up so
that was different to most people I
guess
um I think my mom thought that by
homeschooling me that she would like
that I would like
turn out a certain way
like Little House on the Prairie kind of
stuff
but I I came out very
very me like very um strong personality
so
that didn't happen and then um
when
when I was about like 9 to 11 I can't
remember exactly when but my dad started
drinking and he became really abusive so
like
just being braided every night like
it's all like what's wrong with you and
just like verbal and some physical abuse
and that obviously made me go much
darker like much more depressed
and um I think that threw my mom off a
lot more
yeah
what kind of kid were you in high school
huh what kind of kid were you in high
school
for high school years I guess high
school years
I was sad yeah I was really depressed
um mostly because of the the abuse that
lasted for years so it just left me
feeling like there's something deeply
wrong with me
um is that what it kicked in kind of as
a teenager
yeah I would say well
I think it really kicked in at 12.
because that was when I started um
self-harming so I started cutting when I
was 12.
and that lasted
all the way throughout when I was 17 I
did that a lot it was it's like an
addiction it's really weird like I
couldn't stop doing it you know
and then um there was no abuse sexual
abuse saying like that in your in your
childhood there was outside of my family
so is it I was molested when I was
about five or six but it was a person
outside of my immediate family
and that was really dark
just interesting because I I diagnosed
OCD and OCD makes me feel a lot of
really really heavy shame like
unbearable shame and I remember when I
was trying to figure out what was going
on with me
the only shame that I could remember
having felt that was as bad as OCD was
after I got molested and I didn't know
what to do about it
because I just remember like as a child
I guess Depression started earlier than
I thought because like as a child I went
into like a dark depression and my mom
was like
she just kept asking me every night
she's like what's wrong what's wrong and
I didn't know how to verbalize it
because I didn't really know what was
happening so
but I went to her credit she didn't stop
asking until I was able to tell her
everything and it's not even like I
didn't want to tell her I just didn't
know how
you know and then um
she was able to be like you know it's
not your fault all that like you didn't
do anything wrong
and then that that was
wrapped up
like it didn't haunt me too bad you know
I didn't even realize what had happened
until I was like 19 actually and then I
like went to therapy and my therapist
was like were you ever molested and I
was like nah I was like this weird thing
happened once and she was like
that's being molested I was like oh [__]
I guess I was
oops
and the the emotions you're going
through typically are depression
yeah I mean
in hot well regarding that or just in
general in general I guess in high
school it's just like a lot of really
heavy depression and self-harm and then
just intense anxiety so it just bounced
back and forth and I just like never
felt
I guess I never felt wanted or loved
Maybe
that was it like when I try and think
about it because I was always like
chasing boys like I needed to feel like
that someone wanted me really bad you
know
so that was that was a hard time
and then
I was able to work through that I I had
some PTSD from
from this what my dad used to do because
it was every night
from like
7 P.M till whenever he got tired I guess
I just remember being like pushed into a
corner and screamed at essentially every
night for hours
and that
I guess [__] me up more than I thought
because then even after it ended because
he ended up apologizing you know stop
drinking as much
and which I appreciated but um
after that in high school every night I
would have panic attacks from about when
the sun started going down about 7 pm to
like
midnight 11.
and all through high school and I never
knew what it was I just thought there's
something wrong with me you know
but it was until recently that I I
looked back I was like oh my body is
going through flashbacks I just didn't
know why
you know and now I'm able to deal with
the nighttime much better
um it actually switched now I'm really
nervous in the mornings
yeah but that's because
um when I was diagnosed with OCD waking
up is the hardest part because all the
thoughts just come at you the second you
wake up
how bad is your OCD
right now I'm managing it
when I was first diagnosed it was
horrendous like
the worst I think the worst thing I've
dealt with ever
and it's so confusing because people
don't know what it is and I didn't know
what it was like you see like on TV like
oh it's like you're very particular
you're very anal or
you know neurotic you have to clean
everything you have to have everything
in order and well sometimes that's a
symptom that's not what it is at all
it's like
it's like your brain gets
snapped a little bit and you get stuck
on a loop
so like
say you get a thought
like say you're with somebody and you
see someone that you think is attractive
and you go like oh that person's
attractive
then your brain will be like what'd you
say
you'll be like nothing I didn't say
anything it'll be like you thought they
were attractive
and be like wait what and then it'll be
like you don't love your husband you
don't love anyone you're not capable of
loving anyone you can't do this you
can't do monogamy blah blah blah blah
blah and it doesn't [__] stop like it
just doesn't stop it'll be
it was like a
probably a year until I got diagnosed
and like the themes will switch so like
it it attaches itself to whatever is
most important to you usually
and
it like bounced around so it which makes
it really tricky because then you're
like wait is it OCD if it's okay now I'm
not terrified of like relationship
questions but then all of a sudden I was
terrified that I was going to commit
suicide because I was really depressed
because of the OCD and it was just it
felt like there's a vice lock on my head
and it was just crushing it
and then
I was terrified of that and I didn't
think it was OCD I thought I was really
just gonna have to go kill myself even
though I didn't want to you know but
like I was afraid part of me did so I
wouldn't have a choice
and then like I almost checked myself
into a hospital
and then um I was able to talk to some
friends good friends of mine and realize
it was OCD I had just switched
because the very thought of it just sent
me into like a panic like they call it
like this the tip of the Spear of
anxiety OCD because of how intense it is
and then some people have like Harmony
CD where they're afraid that they're
gonna like like stab their best friend
as like stupid as the thought is like it
becomes so obsessive you can't get your
brain out of the loop and it just
tortures you
definitely essentially you know until
like
you learn how to work around it
and um
finally I
I had learned I had learned enough to be
like okay I do have OCD it's bouncing
around a different topics but I this I
know this is what it is
and um
the like gold standard is exposure
response prevention therapy
which is
so shitty because the only way to like
get over the terrifying thought is to
expose yourself to the thought and not
react to it for like an extended period
of time to force yourself to deal with
what you don't want to deal with yeah to
deal with it but you're not even dealing
with it in the fact that you're you're
not like processing it you're just like
scary not reacting to it not reacting to
it you're also scaring the [__] out of
yourself so like say say You're really
afraid like you're gonna jump off a
building or whatever so like an exposure
would be like
okay you're gonna go stand on a building
and say maybe I'll jump off
maybe I won't
you know and like be safe obviously but
like but it won't feel safe
or like even like with the harmony CD
you all have to sit there with a thought
and be like I am going to hurt the
person I love the most then the anxiety
will [__] shoot up like higher than
it's ever shot up like you'll be crying
and everything and then just keep saying
that same thought that's like
traumatizing you and eventually it comes
down to
a lesser level
and then you can move on from that
exposure and you have to do that a lot
like a lot a lot
and um
I call it a monster like I write music I
have a band called graves in the bad
weather and um almost all our stuff is
about mental health but a lot of the
songs I
I reference a monster
and like standing up and just staring at
a monster that's just like blowing hot
air in your face and you just have to
like like stand still and just like
endure it until like the temperature
comes down because
that's what exposures are like there's
no way around it like it's not like is
that monster your dad no it's the OCD no
but does it represent your dad
uh how do you mean
a corner oh well
the monster I'm referencing like when
I'm writing isn't my dad I mean that
used to be a monster you know like
when I was younger it's a young child to
a child oh my God yeah I was like when
you're a kid and your parents are
telling you something's wrong with you
like or they're big and they're just
they're screaming at you in the corner
yeah you're certain something that's a
monster well it yeah and it convinces
you something must be wrong with you
but I
I think that looks a little different
than like so like what real life trauma
is and then what like mental disorder
trauma is I feel like they're different
you know what I mean
because like
the mental stuff is it's inside your
head you know what I mean and you have
to do these certain things to get over
it like real life trauma
it affects you deeply and affects Who
You Are
but you handle it differently than you
would like a mental disorder I guess if
that makes sense
are there other
things you've mental disorders you've
dealt with
yeah
yeah the other one is um it was called
the depersonalization do you realization
that one kicked in when I was in my
early 20s
um
so like I said when I was in high school
I was really anxious
and there's something about anxiety it's
horrible but it also like gives you a
feeling of control like when you're
worrying about something not just
general anxiety that lives in your body
but like when you're worried about
something if you're consciously worrying
about it it makes you feel like you'll
be able to control whatever that is
so I I was doing a lot about just like
like
active worrying
when I was like in my late teens 20s
and
one day I just woke up and I felt like I
wasn't there
like
I felt like I was in a different plane
of existence and it freaked me out like
it felt like vertigo it felt like um
being in a video game like you know when
you're in a first person shooter or
whatever how like you see her hands but
everything's like separate you know
because it's a separate world
like I woke up and everything looked
like that and felt like that and it
freaked me out so I like changed my diet
like changed a bunch of things nothing
helped
and then
it I just stayed like that for like a
year year or two
and I thought I thought I had like lost
my mind like I thought I was really like
just gonna devolve into myself and just
like disappear
because it makes you feel like you're
you're leaving reality
like your hands don't look like your
hands your voice doesn't sound like your
voice
there were some times I would talk on my
voice that'd scare me like because it
sounded like it was coming from like
outside
and yeah I had no idea what it was
I thought maybe it was like a demonic
attack or something I had no idea
and then um one of my friends
told me
the about depersonalization what it is
and I was like yeah that's what I have I
feel like I'm dreaming all the time and
there's no reprieve from it there's no
escape from it
so she directs me to a website and the
number one thing I recommended was
guided meditations
which I was like I was like okay like
that's not gonna work like that's too
easy so like I went so long without
doing it I just like was you know just
being miserable
and then one day I just finally
caved I was like okay I have nothing
left to try like I have to do something
so
I started doing the guided meditations
twice a day and um
after like a month I noticed like I had
had five minutes where I would I didn't
think about the fact that I felt like I
wasn't there
and I was like oh my God that's huge
progress when like your whole life has
become one way you know
and then all of a sudden you had like a
five minute reprieve you're like okay I
think this might be working
so I kept that up
for again probably about a year and
after a year I finally felt like normal
again like Baseline normal
and it's still like
flares up sometimes so like if I'm not
like doing active rest or like guided
meditations or if I'm over worrying
about things I'll start to feel like
like I'm floating you know floating away
like I'm not here
but then I so basically I just have to
remind myself like ground myself
meditate like
it's funny because I struggle so hard
with consistency in my life but like the
only thing that keeps these like mental
disorders at Bay is being consistent and
disciplined
and it's really hard to be disciplined
are you taking any medications or
anything like that yeah
yeah I'm taking
um an SSRI and then I'm taking an
antipsychotic that works as an
antidepressant
so
I'm not sure if the SSRI does anything
I was just doing whatever they told me
when the OCD was at its worse because
have you been diagnosed with you know
BPD or
no bipolar or schizophrenia nothing like
that no I was afraid I had schizophrenia
but then I realized that was an OCD
theme for a while
they thought I might have bipolar in
high school but they medicated me for it
and it went really bad so they decided
that that wasn't a thing that I'd have
to deal with
the medication helps
yeah like I said the ssris I'm not sure
how much it helps but the the
antipsychotic one helped a lot with the
depression
yeah because for a while I was just
crying all the time just
super sad
I mean that's been like a theme
throughout my life like in and out of
like severe depression how old do you
know I'm 32 32 how is this impacted your
adult life how has it impacted it yeah
as hard
I mean I've had in the past I've had to
leave work early because I couldn't
like emotionally function
it doesn't happen a lot
because I'm
I don't know I feel like I can't like
not use it as an excuse but like I just
feel like a really strong like
sense of like I have to get my [__] done
you know what I mean but when I
objectively look at it like
I probably
should have been on disability at some
points
um it can make my relationship really
hard
I mean my husband's wonderful and like
really patient but when the relationship
OCD
flares up like it it just makes me feel
miserable about like and question
everything like about relationships so
it can make that really hard and I could
see if I was with
um a more sensitive person that it could
probably wreck a relationship
but like I said my husband's really
he's really grounded and um
like patient that's great yeah no it's
it's really great yeah he's awesome if
you had your life to live over again
what would you have done differently
anything to live my life over it would
you have done anything differently
regarding all these things that's a
great question
knowing what you know now knowing what I
know now
I probably wouldn't have been so hard on
myself
with the OCD I wouldn't have been so
hard on myself because I would have
known what it was what it was that
there's not just something deeply wrong
with me as like a human
you know these thoughts are part of a
disorder that's the worst part is just
not knowing what you've got oh it's
horrible because there's something
terribly wrong with you I don't know
what it is yeah it always averts back to
like I'm broken something's very broken
and even if it is something that's
broken that you can fix like that's
different than being like no I am just
like innately a broken person it's just
right oh I'm bipolar and that was just a
little episode right but you're just
crazy don't know why yeah yeah and you
don't know why you're like oh well this
is the end this is it
yeah is there anyone anyone else in your
family that suffers from anything like
this
my dad had depression and my mom I think
does too my mom has anxiety
nobody that I know has OCD which is
weird because that's really genetic you
know so if they're just not diagnosed or
or I'm I'm the first
um as far as the derealization
depersonalization
I know my mom felt that way once like
when she smoked weed as a teenager
and um
that was actually the first time I had
ever felt it was when I smoked weed so I
stay away from that now that's a he
doesn't use any substances
no I smoke cigarettes I guess that's a
substance yeah it's addictive so no I
don't I don't like to feel out of
control
you know it scares me
but
yeah yeah I know depression runs in my
family a lot what do you worry about
most what do you worry about now
I worry about whether or not
my life's gonna turn out the way I want
it to I know that's really vague
but I I know like so I can do so many
things to make my life the best it can
be so I can be disciplined I can work
hard at certain things but it's the
unknown that I stress out about like the
things I can't control like
opportunities or
or yeah just opportunities and stuff
um
I stressed out about that
and I try I try not to I try to just
like you know have faith and
remember worrying about it does it give
you more control over it you know but
imagine having some of these
disorders I guess
I'll we'll call them
um
it almost feels like you're
self-sabotaging yourself
like OCD if if it flares up the wrong
way the morning of a job interview
you're you're just not going to do well
yeah that's scary
yeah and it just comes out of it's not
something you can turn on or turn on no
that's 100 true
yeah that used to be something that
terrified me it doesn't scare me as much
anymore
but having a mental illness or a mental
disorder flare up on an important day as
I'm saying yeah absolutely I remember um
before I got married I I wasn't
diagnosed with OCD yet but I had the
personalization and I was so scared I
was gonna feel like I wasn't there on my
wedding day like I was gonna feel like
out of it and that bothered me for like
a year or two before I even got married
how many years you've been married
um coming on sticks I think
yeah we've been together for I think 12.
your husband understands what you're
going through
yeah as much as anyone who doesn't go
through again
do you have kids no no kids
do you want to have kids
I don't know
it's scary it's a scary thought because
you know OCD
makes everything scary you know
um
I don't know if we could because I'm on
I have a a condition called iih it's
called it's um idiopathic intracranial
hypertension so it's where there's
kind of too much spinal fluid in my
brain so it pushes on my eyes
so there's a medicine I have to be on
for that that I don't know would be
conducive to pregnancy and same for my
mental health medication
so that would be a huge
that's a huge I don't know because I
don't know if I could get off the med
salon
you know
yeah that's a question I get asked a lot
especially because I'm 32 you know and
we've been married for a while
I just kind of leave that one up to God
like I don't know if I get better maybe
I mean we
we play music a lot that might be hard
to do with a kid
but it's doable I've seen people do it
but it seems like these
problems you have are kind of subdued
somewhat now at this point of your life
there I know how to manage them I guess
if that makes sense you know so like
this
like a week or two ago my OCD flared up
really bad
and um
I I gotta just go outside and do
exposures and they're horrible and you
know I felt like I was dying
but then I kept doing it and what do you
think causes the flare-up like that
one school of thought is that um
you should be doing exposures every day
you know and then
you're much less likely to get triggered
um I tend to do exposures till I feel
better and then
pretend it doesn't exist
you know but it isn't some of it just
brain chemistry that's out of balance
yeah I mean yeah the part part
of your brain isn't working
I've heard I've heard the serotonin
I don't know the details of it but
something to do with serotonin and OCD
are connected
yeah they say that so that's why they
prescribe ssris for OCD they say it
helps with a lot of people it didn't it
didn't take care of mine it might be
helping a little bit
but it didn't like fix it I don't know
exactly I've seen pictures of like brain
scans of like people that don't have OCD
and people that do and they're lit up in
completely different ways like there's
just weird [__] going on in there I'm
not sure exactly what
um I thought about doing like those
brain mapping things and like trying to
fix it I don't know like
just experimental stuff but I also get a
little nervous to do that because then
what if that goes wrong I don't want
another thing
you know
Leandra what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in in
all of this
be patient
and have hope
that's something that's been on my mind
a lot lately
is don't like um
don't run into something bad and just
assume it's going to be like that
forever
because I assume it's going to be like
that forever most times even still
sometimes they do that
but I think it's really important to
yeah I just have hope
because things can and do change you
know what I mean sometimes it takes you
take an action but
that's still a way of change
you just have to be consistent I guess
and keep learning
all right Deandra thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you I wish you
lots of luck thanks thanks